laughs okay quickly and one of the
questions that need to be answered is
how can I get to know somebody in a
halal manner because unfortunately a lot
of you think that Islam is you don't see
the person you want to marry it's just
you may you meet on the wedding day and
Hollis you get married and obviously we
know that's not the case how could one
go about getting to know the opposite
gender in a halal manner you know before
I answer that let me quickly tell you
that my brothers and sisters I'm not
encouraging you to just bypass your
parents your parents are the most
important figures in your home's in your
house there is so much of Rights they
have you must discuss these matters have
an open relationship with them but what
I am trying to do is those of us who do
find ourselves in this type of
opposition predicament I'm asking the
parents to be more understanding and to
let things happen you know I have
children I have ideals for them but
trust me and I have proven myself if one
of them would come to me and tell me I'm
interested in marrying so-and-so I'm
interested in two things Deenanath luck
you have it and you're interested in
both parties are interested I am only a
facilitator of what Allah has instructed
me to facilitate that's all what happens
happens later
please let's open our eyes and continue
so regarding the question of how do I
meet in a halal way halal dating and I
think we will end with this one right or
one more okay no problem no problem okay
we still we still there
you're still the mayor so basically
halal way of its not dating it's
actually meeting you see in Islam it's
actually a Sunnah to see your spouse you
know you speak to the person you meet
them but it must be under supervision so
that you're not abused I tell you the
main thing is the issue of a chaperone
so if you have a girl for example she's
seen a brother
it can happen and she's interested
wallahi the best way of doing it is you
get hold of your own brother your father
you know I have such a relationship with
my children I will do
for my daughter any day and if she's
interested in someone I'll go meet him
and so on and tell him hey listen you
know my daughter's showing an interest
for example in you and let's just get to
know each other you know what do you
think and I can gauge and I don't
involve your chaperone after you already
aborted once you know what I mean
after everything's over you're already
in such love that there's no way that
you're going to take no for an answer
that's a mistake that people make you
involve your family far down the line
see so what happens is initially they
will look and and they will then
introduce you officially I'm here for
example and you can be seated there and
have a nice chat mashallah coffee a tea
I might not be able to listen in to
exactly what you guys are saying but
mashallah you're you're under the eye
there's no kissing no touching no
nothing because why they can't be
emotions at that stage you're talking
you're discussing what do you like well
you're not like you see how the person
speaks how they look they stand how tall
short all these things it's permissible
to look at these things okay so if
you're satisfied you can let your
parents know if both of you are
satisfied and you're happy and
hamdulillah if not nowadays a lot of the
people say I need to meet you again it's
not enough so you meet again and you
meet again and you meet again every time
similar condition there is no
restriction as to the amount of meetings
some people come to you say no you must
meet once and that's it you know what
you bring the tea in and you just say
Salaam alaikum and you walk out and he's
seen the tea subhanAllah a wise guy will
say hang on hang on hang on you brought
me milk tea I don't want milk tea I need
another cup of tea
I need green tea and then she speaks to
you and then trust me the tea business
was belonging to the 1960s and 70s so
hon Allah at the moment it's cappuccino
guys so you need to know you're allowed
to meet you're allowed to talk you're
allowed to have a coffee together you're
allowed to sit and chat you must know
because the last thing you want is for
your daughter to marry a guy who's only
marrying your daughter because he wants
to please his parents but he's got
something on the side and your daughter
is banished what lie it's happening
every day it's happening and they tell
you two years later I never wanted to
marry you I've already got my girlfriend
I've already got three children from her
and so on and you like why didn't you
tell me well I did it for my parents the
punishment of the
perrance is severe you destroyed the
lives of people so it's best to be
honest to say listen we're wasting time
I've already got someone my parents are
just being funny thank you so much I
respect you I salute you
shukran I will say no for you thank you
so the person will go back and say
listen no it shouldn't even get to that
you should have an open relationship but
the problem with us we saw hypocritical
we allow our kids to go everywhere but
when it comes to marriage no you can't
made him dad I've met 3,000 men in my
life the man I want to marry you don't
want me to meet him what's this what's
the problem where are you what's
happening I've had lecturers who were
male I've had everyone who was and the
man I want to marry you not even lying
to me to meet him under supervision and
the next thing that that's is okay under
supervision so he comes and he sits
right here right what do you want to say
say it take it easy take it they know
they're on a new the new generation
there is a generation gap we are not
compromising the Dean we are only
showing you how it works up to Kiama
don't come and implement your own
culture here when it contradicts the
Dean if it doesn't contradict the Dean
by all means you're more than welcome if
it does you're not welcome may Allah
forgive us so you meet once you meet
twice you meet three times and then if
you're not happy respectfully shukran
thank you so much and so on another
thing when you have a chat I can have
your number yeah you can you know what's
the proper way I would like to suggest
I've seen I've seen young girls and and
boys as well sometimes being bitten by
statements of you know emotional value I
love yous and miss you send me a picture
please send me one without your hijab
send me one this way that way and I know
of Muslim children who send each other
nudes and they come out they release
their blackmail or child watch are no
matter how deep you think the
relationship is don't do something
unacceptable me but guess what my
brother's going to be the third person
in the group he will be dormant and
quiet the guy says but don't be don't be
so food just be realistic come on how do
you know what if you really interested
in marrying me you will agree what do
you have to hide you're going to be
living these are your in-laws man come
come on to the chat it's the three of us
let's talk
and see he won't be able to say oh wow I
haven't yet seen your legs man you know
because why brother is there it's only
done for your protection your heart
isn't one of the most valuable organs
you know the heart and the mind are the
most powerful organs of the body do not
allow anyone to control those two
because they can hurt you very badly
it's Allah Allah will control Allah
decides you gave your heart away do you
know they have the capacity to break
your life and sometimes we do it too
soon Subhan Allah may Allah help us I've
just mentioned a little bit of what I
feel there is a lot more but inshallah
me and Ali that way we're going to get
together sometime and make a few videos
of Sharla Allah grant each other and
last question I mean yaki I mean I mean
I was expecting it tell me if you don't
want to make videos with me it's okay
that's fine
how can i okay that how can I make my
Haram relationship halal is Haram but I
want to change my ways okay number one
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo